so the NFL and the NFLPA have discussed
the concept of coming together and maybe
loosening their stance on medicinal
marijuana which is obviously banned
within the NFL but there is a big belief
that it certainly could help with
recovery Kyle Turley of course is a
former NFL player offensive lineman and
has been outspoken on this issue and
joins us now Kyle let's start with this
we've been having this debate today a
guy is made to look cooler if he's
holding a football for a living like a
quarterback or holding a guitar for a
living like a rock star I gotta go with
the football man it's taken over the
world that's for sure so if a guy
walking down the street is like a three
and he's holding a football does he be
how high does it get like if he's if
he's a real quarterback like a guy like
who's the guy you played with that he
would say that guy in real life is ugly
but because he's a quarterback he was
good-looking I don't know if it has
anything to do with the quarterback the
quarterback Sam really been uh you know
put holding up to that mark lately over
the past few years as far as books are
concerned it used to be that way the
good-looking guy now it seems that it's
in the other positions you know these
reality shows are hosted some of these
guys the tight end and these dating
shows I don't see any quarterbacks on
those lately wait a minute you just you
just opened up a can of worms are you
saying that the tight end position has
caught up to the quarterback position
and looks well you know you got a couple
folks out there that look like movie
characters at the QB position uh but
very very very few yeah Tom Brady
doesn't get out there he's already
locked down I just don't see when my
wife watches these ridiculous shows any
of the quarterbacks around you know I
see these tight ends Wow
the Travis Kelsie's Rob Gronkowski's of
the world amazing they may be surpassing
the receivers
yeah you know wide receivers tight end
quarterback sir you know I mean Andrew
Luck he's not going on the
you know bachelor anytime soon but if
you look okay you just brought up your
wife Dale Kyle if Angelo new role if
they'd make up burbs to get that rap
but if luck was walking down the street
and he wasn't a quarterback your wife
wouldn't turn her head but because he's
a quarterback don't you think more
people would look pasa if he's holding a
football yeah after that he told him the
football uh before we get into the
marijuana thing also I want to ask you
we've been having fun with this today it
is Tom Brady's 40th birthday obviously
he's a guy that has everything the
Patriots didn't unbelievable thing they
actually bought him goats and they have
a goat petting zoo at camp today which
is amazing if Kyle clearly if cut is
true if Kyle Turley could be gifted one
thing from Tom Brady you would want what
from Tom Brady
I want that year back when the Patriots
wanted me to come back but I was are
done with my career at three more
surgeries and Sergeant said now I'm a
time to to beat up and that's what I
would like that because that's the only
regret I have not going back to that gen
tear and playing for the Pats
interesting good answer um so take me
through this what is the NFL stance on
marijuana and what do you think it
should be well it's not a very serious
stance I mean it's only one test a year
after that you can participate using
marijuana if you want or any other
street drugs for that matter as long as
you don't test get in trouble it's a
one-time agir test for street drugs so
the other stance hasn't been too serious
about it more than it's been about a
kind of dummy check if you you can't you
know settle it down right before
training camp before you take this test
and you know then we're looking at
character flaws here because it's been
looked at for too long as this you know
recreational drug and what I've come to
know about many other players and other
Americans millions across this country
now with all the medicinal states that
this is far from a recreational drug I
don't even believe in that whatsoever
anymore from what I've seen or that
anybody uses it recreationally what
should it be used for for NFL purposes
let's a medicinal use on a percent I
mean it was introduced to me my second
year in the NFL is for medicinal purpose
the player saw me stir
ugly Sami going to the trainer's
constantly for advice and answers is how
I can use you know these other pills for
sleeping these other pills for my moods
for all these other issues who are you
know coming up and they saw I wasn't
getting relief and they said try this
and I said okay well I can't because I'm
not going to be one of those guys that
gets you know popped out the league for
that and they explained about the policy
to me I was still naive about it because
of the n-c-double-a and just getting out
of you know that system where it's
constant random drug testing but what we
know about the silence today is
undeniable in that you know our
government owns a neuro protective
patent on this not any one of the psych
drugs that they prescribed me from
wellbutrin depakote and zoloft and all
these others that NFL doctors
recommended and prescribed to me Divya
does the government own a neuro
protective patent on so on top of the
other pain issues and dealing with the
opiate epidemic and how we can resolve
that now campus is going to prove very
quickly now that the NFL is saying that
they're going to work with the Players
Association that cannabis is the true
medicines for athletes period take me
through a tangible example I'm talking
with Kyle Turley former NFL offensive
lineman so a tangible example and and
let's let's use it as if the NFL and NFL
PA actually do partner on this which is
so hard to believe they're gonna partner
on anything but anyway let's let's just
say that that happens so are you saying
game is over all of you guys are just
the crap has been kicked out of you for
60 minutes is it in the locker room that
is being almost administered by team
doctors and so on and so forth where
it's actually controlled by the NFL
within their environment I don't believe
that that that should be for any America
I think every American shout out a
choice and medicine be able to use it as
they choose you know so I don't believe
in control and all these other things
this is a obviously haven't be able to
control medicine in their locker rooms
and so that's what the professionals do
this and I'm hoping that they are held
accountable to who they're working with
on this research because there are a lot
of people that would like to not see
this happen and so
to put restraints and restrictions on it
is something that doesn't need to happen
the more things they should never have
for bass they should ever test for it
that like NFL should never test or
harder often okay
never again Jerry Jones himself said
that they should drop their proficient
on marijuana
what percentage of NFL personnel non
players do you think smoke marijuana non
clear so elapse
I know coaches ministers administrators
owners I mean come on you you're telling
me or say so never burn one down you got
to be kidding me
you know these guys Jerry Jones I never
saw him silver at a function ever so you
can't tell me that one time or another
these guys haven't participated in it
and players know it and there's a lot of
player coaches out there and other
coaches know it again that's why the NFL
my opinion hasn't taken a serious stance
on it like you know carried over the
n-c-double-a random testing for
marijuana they know that this helps
players and they you know coaches have
been quoted as saying they'd rather have
their players Stoneman on a bunch of
pills so you know once we get to the
science of this and start talking
educated about this you know is going to
be the difference have they asked you to
help with this at all no I that's
probably the further you know far
stretch that they would come and try to
talk to me any you know of us that have
created this stir and forced them to you
know pretty much take a stance where
they have because they're going to
continue to look ignorant as the science
is unfolding
I hope they would I got a lot of answers
I've you know this is I'm here because
of this cannabis saved my life period
you know you can we can talk semantics
we can throw all these negative things
around it smoking and blah blah blah the
end of the day this plants not killed
one soul in history of the world and
almost lost my life to opiate addiction
and psych medications and how horrific
side effects and so you know many of my
brothers as well out step voices a lot
alone I do it and that's why I've stood
up beside all these guys and for these
guys and it continues to grow what do
you think is really going to happen now
what do you think the next move is they
talk about that they're going to meet on
this and they're going to say there's
letters go
back and forth but what do you truly
believe in your heart of hearts actually
will happen oh well hopefully what will
happen is that the media will hold them
accountable you know they have to be
held accountable to this now and if they
are held accountable what I what I know
is going to happen is we're going to
have a revolution in medicine across
this country that will spread around the
world and people will be healed our
suicide rates will drop the UCLA's
around their own study where they tested
everybody 500 different patients has
come in with traumatic brain injury and
over 95 percent of those and have THC
tested positive in their systems
survived we did not have to receive
surgeries over 85% that didn't have
either surgeries multiple or died and so
we can resolve the death rate and youth
football period and we're not talking
about getting kids high we're talking
about CBD all these other things in the
plan that are non psychoactive that have
unbelievable neuro protection benefits
and what this can view for pain
management getting guys off of opiates
we'll go look at Todd Marinovich out in
the desert making a comeback you talk
about Tom Brady at 40 that's the story
and it's because of his ability now to
use CBD and these other things that
don't have psychoactivity to keep him
sober but to keep his mind in balance
and that's what it does Thank You Kyle
thank you guys the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience